[Musik]
absolut glücklich wieder hier zu sein
noch neuen lebertretungen und
zusätzlichen 52 Versorgungen von
Verletzten ein absolut positiver Einsatz
ein tolles Gefühl ich bin stolz auf
Steam und wir sind einfach froh dass wir
wieder da sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
sie im Namen des österreichischen
Bundesheeres recht herzlich zum heutigen
Empfang unserer afro-einheit hier am
Hauptplatz in Korneuburg begrüßen
mein Name ist Marcel taschwehr und ich
darf Sie durch das heutige Programm
führen
in Kürze meldet der Kommandant der
afro-einheit mallore Bernhard Lindenberg
an Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
Tanner danach folgt die Anmoderation
eine Schweigeminute die Begrüßung der
ehren- und Festgäste sowie einzelne
Interviews mit Rettern die vor Ort im
Einsatz waren
anschließend darf ich den türkischen
Botschafter und die
Verteidigungsministerin um ihre Worte
bieten
abschließend während die Retter durch
die Verteidigungsministerin und den
kontingenzkommandanten ausgezeichnet
unter den Klängen der Bundes- und
Europahymne wird der Festakt beendet
[Musik]
der Kommandant wird nun der
Verteidigungsministerin melden
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
heute vor zwei Wochen
erreichten uns die Nachrichten eines
schweren und verheerenden Erdbebens aus
der türkisch syrischen Grenzregion
seit diesem Tag haben wir zahlreiche
Bilder von Zerstörung und Leid gesehen
wir haben Bilder von Menschen gesehen
die nicht nur zu Hause sondern ihre
gesamte Existenz verloren haben und wir
haben auch weitaus schlimmere Bilder
gesehen
aber wir haben auch Bilder gesehen die
uns Hoffnung gegeben haben Bilder von
helfenden Bilder von Rettungen von
Unterstützung und dem gemeinsamen Kampf
um Überlebende
bevor wir aber zu den Damen und Herren
kommen die nicht nur diese Bilder
gesehen haben sondern tatsächlich vor
Ort neun Menschen gerettet und 52
medizinisch versorgt haben möchte ich
Sie bitten dass wir gemeinsam innehalten
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam mit einer
Schweigeminute all den Opfern gedenken
und auch den Hinterbliebenen und
Betroffenen gedanklich unser Mitgefühl
ausdrücken
ich würde sie ersuchen sich zu erheben
vielen Dank
bevor wir nun mit dem Festakt fortsetzen
darf ich einige Ehrengäste begrüßen zu
Beginn begrüße ich recht herzlich unsere
Verteidigungsministerin Frau Claudia
Tanner
[Applaus]
es ist mir zudem eine Freude den
türkischen Botschafter eure Exzellenz
Herrn Ozan ja
weiters begrüße ich die
Vizebürgermeisterin von Korneuburg Frau
Helene fuchsmoser
[Applaus]
und als höchster militärischer Vertreter
darf ich den Kommandant der
Landstreitkräfte Herrn Generalmajor
Martin Dorfer recht herzlich begrüßen
[Applaus]
zudem darf ich alle Vertreter aus dem
Bereichen der Politik der Wirtschaft der
Religion aber auch von allen anderen
Vereinen und Organisationen recht
herzlich willkommen heißen
[Applaus]
für die musikalische Begleitung während
des heutigen Festaktes freut es mich die
Militärmusik Niederösterreich unter der
Leitung von Musikmeister
staatsfachmeister Martin Stuttgart
begrüßen zu dürfen
[Applaus]
ganz besonders freut es mich jedoch sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren dass Sie heute
hier so zahlreich erschienen sind und
mit unseren Helden wieder hier
willkommen zu heißen bereits bei ihrer
Ankunft letzte Woche am Flughafen haben
sich hunderte dankbare Menschen
eingefunden um sie unter tobenden
Applaus mit Dankkarten Blumen und
Geschenken zu begrüßen
ich darf die Militärmusik nun um den
traditionsmarsch der ABC Abwehr bitten
und ersuche meinen nächsten drei
Gesprächspartner zu mir wir hören nun
die Klänge von mutig und hilfsbereit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zu meiner Linken darf ich nun drei
Personen begrüßen die zehn Tage im
Erdbebengebiet im Einsatz waren zu
meiner Linken Herrn Oberstleutnant
Markus Bock damit der Führung der
Gruppen an den unterschiedlichen
Schadstellen beauftragt war sehr geehrte
Oberstleutnant was waren denn ihre
ersten Gedanken nach der Alarmierung vor
14 Tagen
ja für mich ist es etwas oder ich bin
etwas untypisch für die Alarmierung ich
bin um 55 am Montag aufgestanden habe
mein Handy zur Hand genommen und habe
ich lesen durch das global disaster
Highlight and cordonation system
earthquake in Türkei seven point eight
und das war für mich völlig klar sofort
einmal den Kommandanten und den Leiter
Aufstellung starb über dieses Erdbeben
zu informieren parallel dazu habe ich
statt der Kaffeemaschine den Rechner
angestartet und mir ein erstes Lage
Befehl Bild verschafft worum es
überhaupt geht wo das Erdbeben
stattgefunden hat und ob Hilfe nötig
sein wird nachdem hier sofort
erkenntlich wurde das ein massiver
impact auf die Völkergemeinschaft
stattgefunden hat war für mich klar
jetzt kommt Afro nach einigen Jahren
wieder zum Einsatz
sie waren dann ja innerhalb kürzester
Zeit bereits im Erdbebengebiet vor Ort
was waren denn die ersten Eindrücke vor
Ort
hör die Zerstörung war natürlich
schrecklich die Bevölkerung leidet vor
allen Dingen die überlebende Bevölkerung
leidet es ist bitterkalt und Türkei
speziellen und Nachtstunden - 6 - 7 Grad
die Leute haben keine Unterkunft wo sie
sich zurückziehen können die Mütter
sitzen mit ihren Kindern am Lagerfeuer
die Männer sitzen und den Lagerfeuern
natürlich wird verzweifelt in den
Träumen gesucht nach den Überlebenden
nach dem letzten haben und gut das noch
zu retten ist dass natürlich Bilder die
einen prägen und die irgendwo ja das
Leben schon auch verändern man sieht
gewisse kleine Probleme die einen Tag
täglich beschäftigen nicht mehr ganz so
ernst
sie haben bereits die Suche angesprochen
unterwegslich einen Gesprächspartner
weiter nach links ich habe hier den
einen der Hundeführer Joachim
brandlhofer neben mir stehen wie lange
trainiert man denn für so einen Einsatz
und sie haben Ihren Vierbeiner ja auch
dabei also wie lange braucht es da
tatsächlich um hier eingespielt zu sein
und sich auf so einen Einsatz
vorzubereiten ja das kommt immer darauf
an auf die Hunde drauf an aber im
Durchschnitt kann man so sagen so zwei
bis drei Jahre dauert es bis der Hund
den einsatztest machen kann und dann
einsatzfähig ist aber der Hund muss ein
ganzes Leben lernen also wir zeigen den
Hunden immer verschiedenste
Situationen und verschiedenste
Schadenslagen
damit die Hunde auf alles vorbereitet
sind so natürlich sowas wie im Ernstfall
kann man natürlich nicht simulieren im
Training oder oder irgendwelchen
Einsatzes
also jahrelanges Training haben sie
bereits angesprochen und wie läuft jetzt
die Kommunikation tatsächlich mit dem
Hund vor Ort an diesen Schadstellen also
wie zeigt er einen Fund an oder wie
wissen sie dass der Hund was gefunden
hat ja die Hunde sind so trainiert dass
sie einmal wissen was sie zu tun haben
also wenn sie so ein
ausgedrückt ein Trümmerhaufen sehen
wissen Sie jetzt müssen wir suchen gehen
dann schickt man den Hund mit einem
Kommando Weg entweder eine verbales
Commander oder mit Handzeichen und der
Hund sucht dann und wo er dann den
geruchsaustritt am meisten
wahrnimmt dort im Idealfall
in der Türkei und bei solchen Sachen
verschiedenste Gerüche die man ja im
Training auch nicht so simulieren kann
muss man den Hund schon genau lesen
können damit man weiß durch sein
Verhalten auch wenn er nicht fällt jetzt
hat er was
danke noch einmal eins weiter nach links
neben mir Wachtmeister Daniel gegen hat
die Anreise ja sogar aus dem Tiroler
Land hier sozusagen in den Osten
angetreten um auch dann in weiterer
Folge in der Türkei im Erdbebengebiet zu
helfen was ist denn ihre persönliche
Motivation auch bei solchen Einsätzen
teilzunehmen und zu helfen
die persönliche Motivation ist ganz klar
dass man Menschen leben retten kann und
der Menschen dort vor Ort helfen
und Sie haben ja auch die Bilder aus dem
Einsatzgebiet erreicht was waren denn
für sie einer der schlimmsten oder auch
einer der schönsten Momente
einer der schlimmsten Momente war sicher
die Ankunft in Einsatzgebiet wo einfach
klar worden ist wie extrem nicht
Zerstörung vor Ort war und was
vielleicht die Bevölkerung die
Überlebenden ertragen haben müssen und
das schönste Moment was ich am zweiten
Tag unseres Einsatzes wie man in der
Nacht noch ungefähr zehn Stunden Arbeit
eine fünfköpfige Familie darunter zwei
Kinder retten können
ich bedanke mich recht herzlich bei den
drei ausgewählten Personen danke für den
Einsatz
[Applaus]
und ich ersuche jetzt die Militärmusik
um ein weiteres Musikstück oder meine
Österreich bevor wir dann zu den Worten
des türkischen Botschafters unter Frau
Verteidigungsministerin übergehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als nächstes darf ich den türkischen
Botschafter eure Exzellenz um seine
Worte suchen
Frau Bundesministerin
Frau
Bürgermeisterin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren von Bundesheer
die Helden aus Hatay
Liebe Österreich in Österreicher und
darunter
Österreicher türkischer Herkunft wie ich
sehe wir sind alle hier heute da
es ist nicht einfach für ein türkischen
Botschafter an so einem Tag
eine Rede ohne Emission zu halten ich
muss Ihnen sagen
heute noch haben wir mit diesem Erdbeben
sehr viel zu tun bis jetzt haben wir
21.020 Tote
und ich fürchte es wird immer mehr
und noch immer gibt es nach Beben
insgesamt bis jetzt
6212 viele von Stärke her 5
mindestens vier also das heißt nicht
einfach zur Zeit das Leben in
Erdbebengebiet es ist ein Gebiet größer
als Österreich Frau Bundesministerin
mehr als zehn Städte davon getroffen
zwischen 15 bis 20 Millionen Menschen
und
ich muss Ihnen sagen
in solchen Momenten
weiß man ob man Freunde hat oder nicht
und ich als Botschafter in Wien habe ich
festgestellt wir haben es euch sehr
viele Freunde
um 4 Uhr morgens hat mich meine Frau
geweckt und gesagt komm wir sollen
schnell gucken
es gibt er es gab Erdbeben an dem Tag
7,7 mindestens in dem Moment was ich
mitgekriegt hatte und vier Stunden
später wurde ich angerufen von
bundesaußenministerium
Generalsekretär Peter lauske tiefen Teil
hat mich angerufen und er hat mir gesagt
was können wir machen
ich danke der Bundesregierung
weil schon um 11 Uhr war ich im
Bundeskanzleramt
und am Nachmittag hat er Bundeskanzler
Karl mehrhammer entschieden weil ich ja
nicht mit ihnen erstmal alles abgestimmt
organisiert und dann bekannt gegeben das
Bundesheer uns helfen würde
es war für uns so wertvoll
diese Entscheidung von Herrn
Bundeskanzler keiner mehr mit zu kriegen
und es war für uns so wertvoll dass
Bundesheer so schnell reagiert hat und
so schnell mit mit soweit ich
mitgekriegt habe mit drei Maschinen
schon in der Türkei war
und
die Mitglieder dieser Gruppe die mit
dieser ganz besonderen Aufgabe und als
Experten als geeignete Personen für
diese Aufgabe in hatayan
waren wir alle die in Österreich leben
die Menschen türkische Herkunft
wir waren alle gewissermaßen erleichtert
das auch aus Österreich
Menschen die in diesem Bereich viel
Erfahrung haben jetzt unseren Bürgen
Bürgern helfen würden und sie haben
wirklich geholfen
neun Menschen gerettet neun Menschen
mehr als 50 Menschen gewissermaßen
geholfen zu heilen
und ich weiß dass sie auch vielen
Menschen die vielleicht nicht verletzt
waren die vielleicht nicht unbedingt von
getrümmern gerettet werden sollten aber
sie haben mit ihren Gesprächen
Unterhaltung Worten viele Menschen auch
Mut gegeben motiviert die in dem Moment
dort keine Wohnung mehr hatten nichts
hatten aber sie waren froh
Bundeswehrsoldaten Offiziere mit Ihnen
gemeinsam waren in ihr Leid geteilt
haben und mit ihnen solidarisch waren
dafür danke ich sehr im Namen meines
Volkes im Namen meines Staatspräsidenten
und ich denke im Namen aller Menschen
türkische Herkunft in Österreich
Frau Bundesministerin hat am Flughafen
gesagt alle Österreicher sind stolz mit
Ihnen
ich bin sicher dass alle Österreicher
stolz sind mit diesen Helden aus atai
aber ich sage Ihnen
auch alle Türken
als Menschen sind mit
Bundesheersoldaten Offiziere die ihn hat
er in der Türkei waren
mit diesen Menschen die Menschen unter
sehr schwierigen Bedingungen
so toll geholfen haben
also wir sind aus Stolz mit ihm ich
danke Ihnen und ich sage auf türkisch
vom Herzen
sie sind
ab jetzt unsere Freunde auf türkisch
sagen wir Durst das Wort bedeutet für
uns sehr viel
Menschen die uns geholfen haben sind
immer unsere Freunde unsere Dost und ab
jetzt haben wir diese ganze Helden als
unsere sehr enge Freunde die werden für
uns wie Verwandten wie Nachbar so nah
sein weil sie mit uns bei diesen
schwierigen Tagen unser Leid erleichtert
haben mit uns gemeinsam alles
gewissermaßen miterlebt haben und Sie
wissen was wir erleben wie wie es uns
ging und sie wissen
dass es wirklich eine große Freundschaft
zwischen uns gibt und dafür kann ich
wirklich
immer nur Danke sagen und deswegen will
ich meinen Rede so beenden damit mich
jeder verstehen kann
danke Österreich
[Applaus]
als nächstes darf ich die
Verteidigungsministerin Frau Claudia
Tanner um ihre Worte bitten
ihre Exzellenz
sehr geehrter Herr Generalmajor Dorfer
Herr Nationalrat der Abgeordneter zum
Landtag Frau Vizebürgermeisterin sehr
geehrte Bürgermeister aus den
Nachbargemeinden eroberst schlechter vor
allem sehr geehrter Herr Major
Lindenberg ganz besonders sehr geehrte
Soldatinnen und Soldaten Damen und
Herren des astroteams liebe Angehörige
richte meinen Blick jetzt auf Sie
wir alle richten unseren Blick unsere
Blicke auf Sie die Sie so unglaublich
fordernde Tage hinter sich haben
in den letzten zehn Tagen eine
unglaublich schwierige Mission
ausgeführt haben die sowohl physisch als
auch psychisch unglaublich anstrengend
war einen Einsatz in der Kälte unter
schwierigen unter gefährlichen
Bedingungen
und ganz offen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
ich glaube wir alle können uns sicher
sein
dass unsere Heldinnen und Helden das ist
für sie Momente gab in denen sie ihre
eigenen Grenzen
überschreiten mussten
das waren unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten die Zivilbediensteten die
Feuerwehr die Bergrettung das Rote Kreuz
das Samariterbund
so viele die mit ansehen mussten welche
verheerenden Schäden dieses Erdbeben
verursacht hat wie viel unendliches Leid
es über die Bevölkerung gebracht hat
sie haben in einer Region gearbeitet die
nach diesem schweren Erdbeben von
Instabilität und durchaus auch
Unsicherheit geprägt ist aber ihre
schnelle Reaktion und ihre unermüdliche
Arbeit die hat dazu beigetragen neuen
Leben zu retten viele Verletzte zu
versorgen und die Not der betroffenen
Bevölkerung zu lindern
glaube wir sind uns auch alle bewusst
dass sie unter schwierigsten Bedingungen
auf auch oft die eigene Sicherheit aufs
Spiel gesetzt haben um anderen zu helfen
und dafür solle ich Ihnen dafür sollen
wir Ihnen größten Respekt ich bedanke
mich bei all denjenigen die es möglich
gemacht haben Frau Witze Bürgermeisterin
gemeinsam auch diese Feier durchzuführen
weil wir die Gelegenheit nutzen möchten
um ihnen zu danken führen mutigen für
ein selbstlosen Einsatz in der Türkei
ich habe in den vergangenen Tagen so
unglaublich viele danke schreiben
E-Mails Nachrichten erhalten für ihren
Einsatz die von offiziellen Stellen
gekommen sind daher Botschafter war bei
mir in der sauerkaserne aber auch vom
privater Seite von vielen türkischen
Bürgern die in österreichischen
Bundesheer für diese rasche Hilfe
unendlich dankbar sind diesen dank
diesen Dank den gebe ich Ihnen gerne
weiter denn sie haben es auch vor Ort
erlebt wie wichtig es ist rasch zu
helfen
mit diesem Einsatz des
katastrophenelements saftrow konnten wir
als österreichisches Bundesheer einen
wichtigen Beitrag zur internationalen
Solidarität in dieser schwierigen Zeit
leisten ihr Einsatz der hat Hoffnung und
Trost gespendet für die Männer Frauen
und Kinder in der Betroffenen Regierung
und es freut mich auch sehr dass es uns
gelungen ist dass wir die Bundeswehr
Zelte die wir dort im Einsatz hatten im
Sinne der humanitären Hilfeleistung auch
dort vor Ort überlassen konnten ich bin
überzeugt davon dass wir durchaus von
großen Nutzen auch sein sie haben aber
auch gezeigt dass sie als Team in
schwierigen Situationen hervorragend
zusammenarbeiten können und daher haben
sie auch eines verdient und das sei an
dieser Stelle auch gesagt
es ist unsere Verantwortung in der
Politik und auch meine als
Verteidigungsministerin zu investieren
zu investieren gerade auch hier in
Korneuburg in die touch-kaserne in den
nächsten Jahren nicht nur in die Kaserne
auch in die Ausrüstung allein in der
Kaserne werden das 716.000 Euro sein wir
werden die Kaserne zu einer autarken
auch umbauen
Soldatinnen Soldaten Werte Damen und
Herren des afro-teams ihre
Entschlossenheit ihre Professionalität
die haben unterstrichen dass wir als
österreichisches Bundesheer nicht nur
mutige Verteidiger unseres Landes sind
sondern dass wir auch jederzeit bereit
sind für humanitäre Einsätze damit haben
sie dazu beigetragen dass das Ansehen
unseres Landes erhöht wird sie haben
gezeigt dass wir eine starke
verantwortungsbewusste Nation sind
am Flughafen ankommen habe ich ja mal ja
durfte ich mit der Lindenberg ein paar
Worte wechseln und da hat er gesagt dass
er sich schon sehr auf seinen Sohn auch
freut der erst 8 Monate alt ist es ist
mir wichtig an dieser Stelle auch den
Familien zu danken den Familien und
ihren Angehörigen meinen Dank
auszusprechen denn sie haben unterstützt
sie haben unseren Heldinnen und Helden
in den Rücken gestärkt damit sie ihre
Missionen erfolgreich ausführen können
und ich glaube wir sind uns alle bewusst
dass das gerade für die Familie Freunde
und Bekannte alles andere als leicht ist
ich bin mir aber sicher dass die
Angehörigen auf sie auf ihren Einsatz
und auf Sie als Teil der Armee unseres
Landes unglaublich stolz sind
ich danke ihnen für ihre großartige
Arbeit für uns selbstlosen Einsatz zum
Wohl anderer sie sind ein leuchtendes
Beispiel für den Geister Solidarität und
des Zusammenhaltes der Zusammenarbeit
den wir in unserer Gesellschaft wohl
mehr brauchen denn je und den wir auch
fordern müssen
ich darf jetzt dann den
kontingenzkommandanten Major Bernhard
Lindenberg die bergretterin Katharina
pfleißl und den Hundeführer Joachim
brandlhofer bitten vorzutreten ich
möchte Ihnen dank für ihre Leistungen
aussprechen wir werden
verdienstmedaillen übergeben
ich bin unglaublich stolz auf sie alle
auf den After Teil unserer Streitkräfte
dass sie Unterland so unglaublich gut
repräsentieren es lebe das
österreichische Bundesheer es lebe die
Republik Österreich danke schön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nachdem die ersten drei Personen ihre
Auszeichnungen durch die Frau
Verteidigungsministerin erhalten haben
ersuche ich den kontingenzkommandanten
Major Bernhard Lindenberg sein Team
unter den Klängen
traditionsmärchen aus Österreich weiter
auszuzeichnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in Kürze wird der Kommandant major
Bernhard Lindenberg das Ende des Festtag
des melden und nach den Klängen der
Bundes- und Europahymne gespielt durch
die Militärmusik Niederösterreich wird
der Festakt offiziell beendet sein
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren bevor sie
ihre Heimfahrt wieder antreten dafür sie
nochmals daran erinnern dass auch für
leibliches Wohl gesorgt wurde und noch
ein löffelgericht so wie ein Getränk zur
Verfügung stehen ich bedanke mich für
zahlreiches Kommen bedanke mich
ebenfalls bei den Helferinnen und
Helfern für ein ausgezeichneten Einsatz
und darf sie unter den Klängen der
Bundes und der Europahymne recht
herzlich verabschieden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
absolut glücklich wieder hier zu sein
noch neuen lebertrettungen und
zusätzlichen 52 Versorgungen von
Verletzten ein absolut positiver Einsatz
ein tolles Gefühl ich bin stolz aufs
Team und wir sind einfach froh dass wir
wieder da sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]